what would you do if my ex was after you
he can have you
dms dating apps i don't have time for
that
i don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe
in grilling them i'm going to be going
on a series of dates to find who
can really wow me this is grilling
my name is dale boomi and i'm here to go
on a date i guess
i reckon i can handle grilling to be
fair if not i'll just
one time early i don't really go on too
many days i'll be real
more time it's just girls get into my
house the number one thing from going on
a date
is like y'all kind of [ __ ] swear cause
like if i gotta sit there with you and
you're looking funny
i can't take any grilling or we can just
sit there in silence
hi what's your name
david david david
what'd you do i'm unemployed yeah
unemployed
why can't you get a job i pray god
provides
so you're unemployed but show me your
mouth so you've got girls and you're
unemployed
so by the grace of god she seems to be
aggressive you know a bit in your face
do you think she's fit that's a decent
decent birthday
do you 100. drugs no do i look like a
soldier you do
what is that no well you got grills you
drip and you
don't want it's just a standard trixie
don't you crazy something comfy so for
some that doesn't work have you got
growth
as i said i pray god provides well
named cheyenne nice to meet you who the
turns up to a date slouch on a chair
like that rude bit of a weak handshake
it's not a job interview i know it's not
but you came out
it's look at you slouching in your seat
as i said i'm comfy i'm coming for
cheers not drinking [ __ ]
not drinking more of a drink more
maggies and stuff oh you like magnums
yeah i'm sorry and i can't i'm still
half drunk now
you're half drunk yeah what have you
been doing
i just had a bit of a wild night last
night yeah wait no firstly
he turns up hungover then he slouches in
the chair
what's the point important coming on the
date what's a wild night for you david
just a little drinking not remembering
much to do drugs
no i don't do jokes how do you not
remember magnums
a lot of them helped me through a wild
night of david i can't describe one
because i usually don't remember them
but what do you do what do you plan to
get up to as i said a lot of alcohol
a few more friends and bear friends and
some more friends
and i like maybe one am i'm passed out i
just get right into it really shooting
i'm not
much on a space or a whole night so you
just don't want to work
and you just party an unemployed
alcoholic
yeah okay so are you one of those people
that says they're an
influencer online because i did actually
look at your social media no
no no does mine look like an influencer
wrong
so what's your instagram about it's just
i just post pictures
but someone posts pictures that's
unemployed
you look like you're living nicely so
you're one of those people that stand
for the ground
no i don't stand i just post so you
don't you don't think they're stunting
wearing grills
there was a video of you you have all
these women around you
in lingerie talk me through that uh
i like to appreciate beautiful woman
does it make you feel like a big man
having women that you've probably paid
to have around
no i never paid for them so you didn't
pay for those women to
stand around you i would never pay for
really i just happen to be friends with
them
so you've got a lot of friends little
women in underwear a lot of female
friends here
guys can't have female friends do you
not want to
have a wife one day to cross that bridge
when you get to it
what are you looking for like a sugar
mama yeah just
having fun at this moment son how can
you have fun if you have no money
you said i don't have money by the way
so how do you have money then you cannot
work in
you don't have to have a job so do your
drug dealer
no what do you do good servant
i don't know what god servant means but
the only thing that came into my head
when he said he doesn't work was
drug dealer where did you find this girl
by the way why is she so concerned about
how i get bread
so do you understand why you're here
today no
you know i want to settle down i'm
childish very childish how am i childish
you're sat slouching your chair you're
actually a bit lousy
and when i'm asking you questions you
don't even answer correctly you just say
god servant that is the critic because
there is no other answer
to that question
what would you say is you're a toxic
trait i don't care enough
i don't like to argue if you try to
argue just just walk off like
you're better for that i don't like
confrontation or
that you know when people without them
long conversations about how they're
feeling and that
that generally don't care enough so
you're not emotionally available
that's a big red flag do you see it as
a weakness if a man's emotionally
available
not really no you don't say the weakness
to have a good stable
strong relationship you need to be able
to communicate so if you don't like
communication
like the confrontation community don't
like stress
i don't like i like my peace of mind i
like quiet
did you get it yeah so you know i don't
do that i just said cool like you can
tell me
2 plus two is ten if that's what you
believe cool well done
that's it oh so you're submissive and
like someone to dominate you then
what where'd you get the word outcome
you just said you if i say
two plus two is ten so therefore you're
submissive
it's fine i love herself i don't know
what the hell happened there
completely no no obviously don't argue
what do you look for um in a woman david
i don't like women that don't have money
but you want to punch off a woman that
has money you don't work and you want a
woman that's got money
let's respect a lot you continue to
confuse
not having a job with having money
how do you make your money then it just
comes to me in abundance
this is the problem with guys today like
you stumped on the gram
front this lifestyle i don't really have
[ __ ] all i don't stunt
yes you do i looked your instagram like
i personally said it's stunning
that didn't just depend on how you look
at it i'm richer in real life than
instagram well i saw your instagram
definitely looks like you're stunt in
you have women you know the watches the
grills
is that real is that really you like who
is the real david
you don't know i really feel sorry for
you
honestly i feel like you need to go find
yourself because i just feel like you're
just a lost soul
because i don't tell you how i make one
you know like you've come here
you're very just meh you know
it sounds like a therapy session at this
point really and truly i mean you're not
wrong
i'm not wrong as in you're lost no no no
why are you meh there's nothing exciting
going on right now
what on this date yeah well drink up do
a shot should we get a shot do you want
a shot
will that lighten your mood what do you
drink to shop um
really okay no that's the devil's drink
so this is how i know
you are not settling down with anyone
you're not a drinker no i am a drinker
just not right nephews i'd
like to it's a bit chilly yeah what's
childish
i like sambuca and i like tequila and i
like salad
juice do you think you're big i'm just a
drinker you're clearly not a drinker so
do you think that you have to
drink a lot to get girls does it give
you confidence
no so you can get girls yeah how do you
get girls
i say hello say hello that's it that's
usually how it starts
like a normal person does so how do
women become interested in you just
invite them to my house
you just invite women into your house no
effort
no do you make effort like what do you
do if you invite a woman over what do
you do
it's been quite a long time since i've
had to really try
to yeah girl it's been quite a long time
it's not just like you know it's when
you're as a kid getting that girl and
you've worked hard for her and it was
like it was like a grind almost
yeah now it's become boring kind of
thing because i don't have to try it too
much
so you're saying girls throw themselves
at you well that's it for themselves
that's what you're saying it doesn't
take much conviction to get them
to my house i find it really hard to
believe that you've got girls
how this happens
what's the most desperate thing like
you've ever done in your life to get a
girl
traveled to a house or something just to
have sex with a girl
really you travel two hours just uh
literally have a beat yeah men will do
the most
just to have sex with you that's
stupidly horny
when you think you're willian not your
head you make some rash decisions
so what happened after did you [ __ ]
chuck her
i just went home you [ __ ] and chucked
her so you went around her house slept
with her
did you bring her back the next day yeah
yeah we smoked
surely you spent more time on the train
than you did
100 because it was never a oh my god i
love you
or some nonsense like that just some
couch
are you the kind of guy that like has to
tell mandem like the girls that they're
seeing and dating
i feel like you're the kind of guy that
would like get a selfie of the girl
you're seeing and then put it in the
lads group chat
girls on a flex maybe as kids it was but
if it's like your actual act right girl
girl
when you're on the post of course it's a
flat spot just oh i'm [ __ ] a girl
that's not flexible
you know how some guys like to record
like how do you
know the difference between like this
woman is a wife
or this woman is just a baby the way i
look i can't go
looking for a wife like and the only
girls that i've kind of
liked it's like we started as friends
like that's how
it should be really and truly because
anything forced is just [ __ ] yeah
would you say you're a good guy actually
100 what makes you a good guy
i'm not a bad guy so many guys say i'm a
good guy
but there's nothing and i think what's a
big issue and i think for
me percy what i hate about men that
claim they're good guys
they just sit and stand around and watch
men be shitty men and then
you want to justify your actions by
going well i didn't do that
i don't see bad things happen to me in
real life at least my bridges aren't
weird i'm under
weird around girls at parties and that
yeah i'm not friends with guys that
i can't know what if you're the weird
friend i really doubt that
i can't go over that image of the video
review with the women
which one they are on your social media
they're
they're
they're
they're
they're
out there well there's a few
exactly having women kind of being
objectified around you what's your
thoughts on that
are you looking at them as objects no
because i'm not
why have you got women around you in
lingerie acting like you're the man
because i've got
friends that are female we just had
discussion to do a
funny video for valentine's that would
kind of go viral that was even more so
there i did than mine
do you find women don't take you serious
because of that they don't take me
serious if i ever
suggest relationships if i suggest that
if i said to someone i've got a girl
they'll probably laugh and not believe
me is it because the way you behave in
your character yeah but that's the way
i prefer it to be no girls ever
expecting a relationship from me they
don't want to so there's no hassle
there's no stress
why wouldn't you ever want that i feel
like because i don't need it right now
there's nothing that a relationship
would do for my life right now you do
not think like relationships is a
partnership it can really make you
elevate
no so what's your thoughts on women
being sexually liberated
as much as men genuinely
i have no thoughts on it at all so if
i'd slept with
your best friend and your brother but
you really liked me would you still wife
me
probably not why not it's a bit weird
because my brother that's
that's that's a strange one yeah i guess
you'll be brother that's the sweet
all right what if it was just your
friends then probably
probably what would wife me yes i liked
nice to know
have you ever had therapy no have you
ever gone through anything traumatic in
your life
no you've had a nice easy life is this
some secret intervention my family's put
me into this is where
it's getting a bit dark my dad died when
i was five
i'm sorry hear that do you think it's
affected you growing up without a father
have you ever gone to therapy no why not
because i don't need to sometimes you
don't realize until later in the life
later down in your life
how much certain things have affected
you so for me i think it has to be fair
there's no i've never had like
oppression or anything like that yeah
so i don't see what i would go there for
i could probably sit there in silence
yeah you're quite quiet aren't you yeah
i don't don't make too much noise really
intruding
why my phone they can't go on there
because even i don't know what's on
there what do you mean you don't know
what when you're on fire i've got like
50 000 pictures
from i don't delete anything so you
might come across something you
may not necessarily want to see or will
raise questions that's just you know
stress for everyone
why would you have things like that if
it's gonna cause stress i thought you
like stress-free life
exactly that's why no one goes on my
phone so why would you have people that
would send you stuff that's gonna give
you
memories and [ __ ] no one's gonna be that
petty to bring up your past and use it
against you i don't know
you'd be surprised with some girls
everything upset some girls yeah well
i'm not some girls
take the answer any way you want no you
don't
i can't answer it because why can't you
answer it
right because [ __ ] might get
misinterpreted and
now i'm getting drawn out would you do
it to me yeah
no one's such about us yeah i don't want
to go near wrong
yeah thank you i appreciate it
yeah i'll say you're definitely not
you're always partying no i'm not always
part of you said you was
but the best way i can explain it i can
go like
time without seeing my family and i'll
be fine if i'm busy or
abroad i can go like months i think the
only person i can't
live without is my little brother that's
it i'm really surprised with that answer
considering you're a man of god
you're not really like family orientated
like how i provide for them but i don't
need to the man that doesn't work
provides the family just always make
things happen
listen i know you're going to say yeah
before you do this like i've seen your
friendship circle
seeing the way you move you know glad
you're finding funny
you've done research for me that's a bit
strange as well what's strange
i know like almost nothing about you you
just said you know my friendship circle
yeah whatever you haven't asked me any
questions
this whole point when you're trying to
get to know someone you have a
conversation ask some questions
no yeah of course you don't i don't like
doing anything
i can pay someone else to do you're lazy
you're very lazy
i don't do you know housework at all or
whatever it's called
i believe in work ethic and just
understanding life and just being a bit
in touch with reality so what do you do
all day
sure are you not bored no no i've got
stuff to do
whilst chilling okay well what stuff do
you do
um like i find it hard to believe you
that you sit and watch
just no i never watch tv so what do you
do you just sit and you just do business
on my laptop
when was the last time you cried i don't
think i remember
you don't remember why
i said i don't have a reason to cry no
she wants me to cry
she wants to know my job what's what's
next so you're not in tuned
or aligned with your emotions i don't
see stuff that's sad
or there's nothing i'm going through or
what about things that's going on in the
world
well would i cry about that because it's
sad you can't be upset about anything
out of your control
that makes no sense it's like crying
that the sky is blue it does make sense
if
you see like humanity like just in pain
and in suffering and people dying and
getting murdered
it's life oh my god that's really
horrible yeah
it's life but why would i cry but what
this is
what does it have to do with me why
would i cry but that's that's so simple
honestly like that's a really selfish
rate of thinking so now that i've cried
have i
what have i it shows that you've got
empathy but for me it's a big red flag
when you're not
emotionally available when you don't
understand or you don't care about other
people
you know i don't care but you just said
like oh that's life
if i see someone's dad halfway across
the world or whatever
but i cry have i saved them
what does it do for anyone i genuinely
believe in change yeah
you know and justice do you just like
the type of person that just sits back
and that's crazy
good
do you want to see me again david um if
there's less
stressful questions stressful very
stressful
i don't think they are i just think that
you had no respect by turning up
hungover
i think a normal man with respect that
came on a date not in a hangover we'd
appreciate these questions
on the first date questions that you
would scare someone off i like to ask
these questions because i like to know
the way you think
these these questions you ask on all
your first dates yeah
because this is scary
what would you do if i asked to see your
dms right now
probably soon now why that's mad that
this day would get locked off quickly if
you read any just first three maybe even
ain't got nothing to do with you so what
you got to do at your wild party last
night
well i don't post snaps and not take
snaps on a party obviously you're a
sneaky person
real life's real life the incidents
things that you get
for instagram or snapchat i'll talk to
people more on snapchat
that's not i feel like snapchat is just
sneaky because it disappears
yeah that's like that's the whole point
why would you want that that's a bit
dodgy people screenshot a lot these days
what are you saying to be screenshotted
if you're a man of god you'd be
surprised what would you do if my ex was
after you
he can have you you can have me i'm not
fighting no i don't think i'm not over a
girl
that's good to know that you're not that
childish to fight over situations
but what if i had done nothing wrong
you'd done nothing wrong and he was
crazy would you not fight my corner no
no because now
my peace of mind is at cost so
i'm not arguing with no one i'm not one
of those toxic girls that likes men to
fight over her
but when he said oh like your ex can
have you
excuse me like i want a man that's going
to fight for me you know in the sense
that just back my corner a bit
so what if man is after me for no reason
just because i'm with you which means
he's after you yeah but he's after me
because he's mad about you
we let the police handle that why am i
fighting the i'm not a superhero
what would you do if i didn't sleep with
you for the first six months of our
relationship
it wouldn't be your first six months
what what do you think
if i was there for six months i'm a
hundred percent having sex with someone
else
why you don't need to like constantly
keep having sex with you
i mean i do would you say you're a sex
addict david
how many times a week would you say is
addicted now
this guy is definitely a sex addict
so do you have a lot of sex then i think
you could consider it a lot yeah
how much is a lot oh no a couple times a
week
is it with the same women or different
women it's different women
probably yeah so you're [ __ ] away no
how does that mean you thought well
how does that not make you a [ __ ] boy i
ain't cheating on no one
i'm not selling no girls dreams do you
not feel like you're like selling
yourself a bit there i had to take a
break
one time because i was having a dumb
amount of sex i started having
nightmares and [ __ ]
and i never had nightmares so would you
say you're easy
there's no judgment no judgment at all
yeah
it got convinced me if i were attracted
to her girl she ain't got to do much to
try to convince me
so what's your thoughts on women that
give out so easy
that's great if they enjoy sex enjoy
what if your friends were liking my
selfies what would you do
nothing at all what what does that mean
i don't know what if your friends are
trying to slide in my dms
it's how you respond would you not pull
up your boy like you're moving mad
that's not yeah
if they're liking your picture like when
we're not 10 years old
what does that mean they message you
that's probably weird
but it happens though guys quite they're
quite sneaky do you trust your friends
why are you having
my friends i do trust but i know a lot
of people
i don't trust on them though would you
say you have an ego david
elaborate a little bit do you think that
there's a man
you know charlie big bollocks i think
you're it because i definitely think you
do
you think that no no not really just
i'll just say a
confident bloke do you know what i mean
like
if you don't love yourself who will so
would you say you're confident
yeah so would you say you're arrogant
no no i think on social media you give
off that image that you're arrogant
i've heard that before i know but when i
look at it i know where they're coming
from
so you admit you look a bit arrogant i
do look arrogant but
i wouldn't say i'm not out did you get
it the thing is for me like i have this
big issue with just people that
are on social media stunt in i don't
know why it just bugs me stunting's when
you ain't got in all that
have you always had money then so you've
been privileged to no always have money
not at all was it a struggle growing up
which is for me i wouldn't say it was a
struggle that
like when i deep it now like we were
poor on that you get it but
i was good that at the time i'm not
going to pretend oh i was suffering
i was good for my age i was happy with
what i had i could never say that i was
hungry so
looking to do what other guys doing
coming out trenches and uh
with that [ __ ] so you haven't come
from the trenches
that was good all right did have a body
but life was still good you get it yeah
how do you think the date's gone david
it's gone around i reckon the day it
would have been just
better if i was fully sober right now
and not with a headache but sorry
apart from the scary questions well if
you just set up
and you know would that change the
question well you could ask me questions
i'm getting to know you by you getting
to know me but i would say you're very
much in charge
yeah i'd say so too yeah because i feel
like i could dominate you
no you don't think that i don't believe
so no i'm confident i could
i'm happy you think that the day was
awful what do you mean how did it go it
was
awful it was all right would i go
link her again no she's scary i'm not to
go out of my way to
see david again if i see him somewhere
which is very unlikely because he seems
to go to
all these parties and have a lot of sex
he's not going to be in the same social
circles as me did i do anything wrong no
of course not
i handled that perfectly well to be
honest with you he had handled the
grilling
okay he looked like he was going to cry
at some point so honestly look at his
eyes she wants you to cry
and she just sucked the whole day like a
bbc news 1
10 pm show i do think he did like me a
bit you know
tried to give the odd smile rare but i
did she 100 like me
i can tell when the girl's so aggressive
she likes you trust me
too many red flags to mention like way
too many red flags she wants to pretend
that she don't care about money but it's
clear that she does
i feel like giving him a four is
generous today i'll give myself like
probably a nine i would do apologize for
the slouch and maybe i should have done
better and pulled up a little bit more
sober
i felt a bit sorry for him like so i'm
gonna give him four
100 yeah i give myself a nine
[Music]
you